the group is beginning to assemble
they have already been prepared with the
use of proper study materials
for the film which is to be shown
the projector is in place
the screen and the speaker are set up
the amplifier is properly set up and the
cord
connected to the projector
the power cord is properly connected
both to the projector
and to the outlet
the light control curtains are ready to
be drawn an assistant is at the light
switch
it is time to start the projectionist
gives the signal and the curtains are
closed
the assistant turns out the light and
the show has begun
everything properly prepared in advance
ensures a good film showing
good film shows are set up in advance so
that there is time to remedy any faults
that would otherwise
mar the show
in this room a film will be shown
shortly
the projectionist arrives early so that
he will have time to set up his
equipment
and check the light control facilities
the ventilation
the power source his own equipment and
the films to be shown
he has already made sure that the power
supply is the right kind
alternating or direct current and that
it is the right voltage for the
projector
the screen is set up in the front of the
room
it is placed so that everyone can easily
see it
the bottom of the screen should be level
with the tops of the heads of those
in the front row
the projector is on a stand the stand is
directly in front of the screen
so that there will be no sidewise
distortion of the projected image
the projector arms are put in place
the take-up belt is checked
the power cord plugged into the
projector is twisted for safety or under
the projector stand
to prevent the projector from being
tipped over if the cord is pulled
when an extension cord is needed the
projectionist twists the cords around
one another before plugging them
together
so that if the cords are pulled or
jerked they will not come apart
after the cord is wrapped around a chair
leg it is plugged into a wall outlet
and the x cord is coiled up neatly
against the wall
the projector is turned on for a trial
run first the motor
then the lamp the image is too large for
the screen
because the projector is too far away
the average 30-foot classroom
an image of about three and one half
feet wide is best
with the standard lens this will result
when the projector is about twenty feet
from the screen
if the projector is closer to the screen
the image will be smaller and too bright
if the projector is farther away from
the screen the image will be larger and
too dim
therefore if the image is too large the
projector must be moved closer to the
screen
the image is now the right size and
brilliance but there is fuzz around its
edge
this is dirt in the aperture of the
projector which must be carefully
cleaned before the showing for the dirt
is not only disturbing to see
but it will scratch the film
after the visual projection has been
checked the sound is connected
so that it too can be inspected
some speakers have their own power
supply and the cord must be plugged into
a wall outlet
the speaker cord is also anchored to the
leg of the table
it is anchored again to the leg of the
projector stand before it is connected
to the projector
now the amplifier is turned on in a few
moments it will have warmed up
and when the volume control is turned up
full allowed hiss will surge to indicate
that the sound system is working
remember that there will be less volume
and less high frequency response
in a room filled with audience than in
an empty room so that the volume and the
tone should be set somewhat higher in
the preparatory projection
the films are placed in the order of
their projection the can should be
opened and left open
so the changes of reels can be made
quickly without interruptions while a
sticky lid is painfully removed
to determine whether the film is ready
for threading lift the film off the reel
over the top making sure that it doesn't
get on the floor where it will pick up
dirt and scratches
holding the end of the film straight up
in the air if the picture or letters are
right side up
and in the correct left to right
position the film is ready for threading
when the show begins you won't have this
or this the picture will be right side
up
and in the proper position all the reels
that are to be projected
should be inspected in this manner
when this has been done the first film
on the program should be threaded in the
projector
after threading the motor is turned on
then the lamp the image is focused and
brought into proper frame
remember that on sound projectors the
sprocket wheels have sprockets only on
one side
because sound films have sprocket holes
only on one side
the sound runs down the other most
silent projectors have sprockets on both
sides of the sprocket wheel
thus silent films can be run on a sound
projector
but sound films must never be run on a
silent machine
to reduce the strain on the film during
projection the film is threaded with
loops
above and below the gate
if the loops are too short they will
tear the film if they are too large they
will slap about
the correct size is indicated on the
projector itself
check to see if there is a spare
projection lamp a spare exciter lamp for
the sound system and a spare fuse to the
amplifier
make sure that the amplifier and the
power cords are in the best positions
check the light control facilities draw
curtains when properly installed
provide the most effective light control
medium the curtain should be hung in
such a way that the hangers run along a
track
the rod and ring method will not stand
up to long wear the track should be
fixed to the ceiling
far enough away from the wall so that
the curtain will avoid obstructions
such as window boxes bookshelves
radiators
or windows that open inwards like this
the bottom of the curtain should be
about 18 inches from the floor
this will control the light but permit
ventilation
here the curtains operate smoothly and
darken effectively
the track for one curtain curves around
the end of the other
thus there is an overlap and no gap is
present to permit the entry of light
everything has now been checked the
light control facilities the film the
projector and the amplifier
the projection is derived early enough
to make sure that all would be working
well
now that the group is coming in he has
assured himself that the show will be
good
there will be no faults or interruptions
to married and attention to the film and
the enjoyment of it
will be undisturbed
when the show is over the room lights
are turned on while the end title is
still on the screen
the projector lamp is then turned off as
soon as the sound on the film is
finished the amplifier is turned off
if at all possible dismantling or
removal should not take place until
after the audience is dispersed
careful preparation produces successful
showing
you